good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight here's a happy memory by
breakfast really even brunch on election
day 2016 virtually nobody in washington
dc thought donald trump could win
and they didn't think that because the
entire press corps had been telling them
for months the trump had as they always
put it literally no chance not even as
an abstract theoretical matter
this wasn't actually a race in fact come
november 8th you'll remember this donald
trump was going to be drowned by a
towering blue tsunami and swept away
forever along with the rest of the
republican party the collaborators
anyway
and polling numbers seem to confirm that
this was going to happen and so by the
way did the private betting markets at
least one of those markets had set the
spread at 80 20 for hillary clinton that
morning
in the end of course they're not only
wrong they were hilariously wrong by
midnight trump had won and a lot of
highly educated extremely well
credentialed people suddenly looked
ridiculous hillary clinton herself was
so shocked by the results that night
that she refused to give a concession
speech
she went to bed hoping it was just a
dream
now you probably remember all of that
very well but it was what happened next
in the days between the election and
thanksgiving
that it turns out in a lot of ways was
much more important what happened during
that period set the course for where we
are right now and where we are right now
is speeding toward one of the great
disasters in our history
so the leaders of the democratic party
couldn't in effect handle the outcome of
the 2016 election they snapped under the
strain of it under the crushed
expectations but rather than look inward
and assess their own role in the
disaster what did we do wrong why did
voters reject us and other questions
that emotionally mature adults might
have asked
democratic leaders instead immediately
set out to find somebody else to blame
for the election results
and soon they settled on russia vladimir
putin got donald trump elected they told
us hillary clinton said that repeatedly
now at first it was hard to take any of
it very seriously we tried but there was
no evidence it was true at all
and so a rational person concluded the
obvious this was a childish
psychological defense mechanism it was
not a factual claim
and yet they kept saying it in the face
of no evidence and over time they began
acting on it like it was true and then
even over more time they paralyzed the
entire federal government for years
fruitlessly trying to prove the core
claims of russiagate but they never
could because those claims weren't true
and yet critically they clung to those
claims they never stopped repeating the
talking point
the russian government quote hacked our
election that was jen saki not long ago
saying it out loud like it were true now
here's the context
as she said that saki was trying to
explain why the biden administration is
in effect working to overthrow the
russian government right now
and for once gensake was telling the
truth that is why
democrats have convinced themselves that
russia stole the presidency which
rightfully belonged to hillary clinton
and they mean it when they say it
and that's why they are taking us to war
with russia
now there are a lot of things going on
here a lot of threads as in any big
story but on some level the core
motivation is just that simple here's we
know it's not we know the war in ukraine
is not about saving democracy please
we know it's not about protecting the
sacred borders of a sovereign country we
know the administration doesn't care
about those principles because they run
our country and we see how they act
and we know for dead certain and this
comes as sad news to a lot of americans
who are compassionate but we know now
that the war in ukraine is certainly not
about helping the ukrainian people those
poor people
many more ukrainian civilians will die
certainly thanks to the bite
administration's policies if you wanted
to save ukraine its people its
infrastructure its nation you would push
for a settlement now you would have done
it two months ago but they're not doing
that they've rejected it out of hand so
that's not their goal saving ukraine
saving human lives no that's not their
goal
instead the war in ukraine is designed
to cause regime change in moscow they
want to topple the russian government
that would be payback for the 2016
election
so this is the logical maybe the
inevitable end stage of russiagate
now we should have seen this coming
because they said it out loud
years ago
here's adam schiff from two years ago
predicting it saying it watch this
as one witness put it during our
impeachment inquiry
the united states age ukraine and her
people
so that we can fight russia over there
and we don't have to fight russia here
so we arm ukraine so we can fight russia
now how many americans whatever you
think of putin probably not much
justifiably probably don't have a lot of
interest in moving to russia but how
many americans then or now want to quote
fight russia
a very small group but adam schiff said
it out loud at the time in the house of
representatives we don't arm ukraine so
we can help the ukrainians they're
merely unfortunate pawns in all of this
we arm ukraine so that we can punish
russia why
for stealing hillary clinton's
coronation
if only we had taken adam's shift
seriously as he said it again and again
and again but now we can't help but take
adam schiff seriously because he's one
of the prime movers of this war adam
schiff spent this weekend in eastern
europe checking on the progress of the
war he has done so much to bring about
he traveled there with nancy pelosi and
a number of other of the most conspiracy
minded democrats in congress these are
the russia gate true believers seeing
their theory come to fruition that's
what this is
here's the group pelosi schiff and the
rest meeting with the president of
ukraine
jim mcgovern massachusetts nice to meet
you thank you reminder yeah we'll see
you again yes
so how did adam schiff and nancy pelosi
wind up in charge of america's foreign
policy as we stand on the cusp of a
third world war
and why are republicans supporting them
and what happens when you put people
with a demonstrated lack of boundaries
or self-control or wisdom in charge of
something as important as the fate of
nations well here's what happens
watch as one after the other the
democrats you just saw on tape announce
that this regime change is not nearly
over in fact this war has just begun
watch
but one thing is really clear that this
delegation wanted to send but also
president biden has made very clear with
his most recent
aid package request
it is a historic request
that we're going to push hard in the
united states congress to help pass
and it sends a very simple message
we are not interested in stalemates
we are not interested in going back to
the status quo
the united states of america is in this
to win
and he will stand with ukraine until
victory is one
that was congressman jason crowe
a confirmed buffoon
telling us that we're not in it to
achieve a stalemate we're really some of
us were under the impression based on
their public statements that we were
defending the sovereignty of another
country ukraine that it's not up to us
it's up to the voters of ukraine because
ukraine's a democracy but here's
congressman crow telling us we're not
going to accept a quote stalemate we're
in it to win it we're going to win we're
here till we get victory
well that raises the obvious question
what is winning what is victory how do
we know when we've won well jason crowe
didn't tell us and neither by the way
did nancy pelosi she just said we're
going to keep sending weapons to ukraine
quote until the fight is done
we believe that we are visiting you
uh to say thank you uh for your fight
for freedom that we are on a frontier of
freedom and that your fight
is a fight for everyone
and so our commitment is to be there for
you until the fight is done
how do we get here exactly
do you feel betrayed
if you're one of the millions of
good-hearted americans who put a
ukrainian flag pin on your lapel or put
one in front of your house expressing
solidarity with the poor oppressed
people of ukraine you probably didn't
think you were signing up for this
nancy pelosi telling us we're in a war
with a nuclear armed power
with no clear end date
seen that movie before oh we just
finished one after 20 years in
afghanistan will it look like that
this is an open-ended conflict said
nancy pelosi just like the war on terror
and just in case you missed it they all
repeated that line here's your nightmare
again adam schiff in charge of the war
against russia watch
the whole freedom-loving world has an
interest in the outcome of this war and
ensuring that ukraine is victorious
and we are determined to do everything
in our power to make it safe
we are proud to stand
shoulder-to-shoulder with ukraine and we
will until
these people are playing dress up they
have no idea what they're talking about
and they don't care they get to pretend
to be statesmen for a day but when adam
schiff and nancy pelosi again people
with a demonstrated years-long record of
being willing to say anything for
personal power anything to improve the
fortunes of their political party when
they're standing up with a foreign head
of state saying here's a
here's an open check
you fill in the number you got to wonder
where this is going
we know where it could go
this is the most reckless foreign policy
in our lifetimes in american history you
are watching a group of decades in some
cases senile leaders casually dismiss
the consequences of going to war with
the nuclear armed nation
dismiss the consequences of nuclear war
like it's not even worth thinking about
but it is worth thinking about they tell
us daily vladimir putin is evil and
insane and that may well be true
but this same man has threatened to use
nuclear weapons against the united
states and western europe if this
continues and why don't we believe him
you may have missed this the new york
times didn't see enough time to cover it
but here's russia's foreign minister
just last week underscoring the point
russian foreign minister sergey lavrov
with a chilling warning the risk of
nuclear war is a real one speaking to
state-run media lavrov said quote the
danger is serious it is real it cannot
be underestimated he added that he did
not want to see these risks of nuclear
war quote artificially inflated
he does not see it as an artificially
inflated sense risk says
lavrov so
what they're saying is
we will use nuclear weapons against you
and your allies if you don't back off if
for example this seems existential like
you're trying to overthrow our
government it's hardly defense of russia
to say that's a real possibility and has
been for quite some time so it was two
years ago that vladimir putin revised
russia's nuclear deterrent policy now
the new policy allows russia to use
nuclear weapons in response to a
conventional strike that means some sort
of non-nuclear provocation now in march
russia's former president dmitry
medvedev who sits on russia's security
council reminded our country of this
policy he warned joe biden that russia
would indeed use nuclear weapons against
the west in response to any quote act of
aggression that is committed against
russia and its allies
now what would that look like would it
include helping to shoot down a russian
transport plane carrying hundreds of
russian troops
the pentagon has admitted doing that
you don't have to be for russia to see
that as a pretty reckless act and not
just doing it but then bragging about it
to nbc news where does that get us
we should find out
we do know that putin has placed
russia's nuclear forces on high alert
and again russia has the largest nuclear
arsenal in the world and again why
wouldn't he use those weapons they tell
us daily he is evil and insane and he
may well be a risk yeah
but no one in washington seems worried
in the slightest in fact congressman
adam kinziger was clearly something to
live for at this point is now calling
for a blank check an open-ended conflict
in ukraine using the same legal
justification that got us into iraq for
nearly 20 years he wants an
authorization to use military force
watch
senator kaine was with us and he said it
is too soon to begin talking about
potential use of force in ukraine do you
think he's right
no i don't i don't think we need to be
using force in ukraine right now i just
introduced an aumf an authorization for
the use of military force giving the
president basically congressional
leverage or permission to use it if wmds
nuclear biological or chemical or used
in ukraine doesn't compel the president
to do it it just says if it is used he
has that leverage there may be a point
that we have to recognize you know look
this is at world wars prior to world war
ii there were moments nobody ever wanted
to get involved and eventually came to
realize they had to i hope we don't get
to that point here but we should be
ready if we do
prior to world war ii says adam
kinzinger so last year adam kinser was a
guy who had been redistricted out of his
own district and was trolling for some
kind of cable news contributorship the
future looked grim for adam kinzinger
now adam kinziger is on the sunday shows
every weekend doing his winston
churchill imitation so you can see
there's a built-in incentive for
mediocre and intellectually limited
members of congress to play the war hawk
but you have to ask yourself why all of
a sudden is everybody talking about
chemical and biological weapons it was
just a couple of weeks ago that joe
biden the president united states
promised to respond quote in kind to the
potential use of chemical weapons by
russia in other words the united states
would use its chemical weapons against
the russians if they used theirs against
the ukrainians and then because you're
not supposed to admit that you have
chemical weapons joe biden's national
security adviser whose memory still
works walked it back and told us oh no
the president misspoke just like he did
what he told us this was a regime change
war we would never use chemical weapons
said jake sullivan
but for some reason a lot of people in
washington in both parties are still
talking a lot about the us using
chemical weapons in russia here's one of
the most limited members of congress
michael mccall republican from texas
widely regarded as a mouthpiece for the
intel agencies listen to what he says
what would happen if a chemical weapon
was dropped in ukraine and or a
short-range tactical nuke the question
there is would the world idly sit back
and watch that happen without doing
anything
what would we what should we do
i i just find it hard to believe when i
talk to the secretary general of nato
their job is really to defend nato not
trigger article five but in my judgment
that
that's beyond the pale that crosses a
red line and i think if that happens
we would have to respond in kind
so stories like this give people like
michael mccaul a chance to give you a
moral lecture on television which is the
whole appeal but again all of a sudden
you have sitting members of congress
with access to high-level intelligence
talking casually about using chemical
weapons or nuclear weapons against a
nuclear-armed state
so it's not a defense of russia you
don't have to believe russia was
justified in invading ukraine they
weren't
it's not a defense of putin to think to
yourself hold on a second here how did
we get here talking about nuclear war on
the sunday shows should we be are we
ready for that it's clear no one in the
bible administration cares or is worried
about it at all
the escalation continues at a remarkable
pace and you know that if you watch the
money we're continuing to shovel cash to
the government of ukraine which just
last year democrats described as one of
the most corrupt in the world but
whatever
and we're sending money to ukraine at
levels that are astounding joe biden
signed off on a funding package in march
for 13.6 billion dollars in aid for
ukraine then he sent an additional 1.3
billion in late april then he sent 350
million in february he also sent 800
million in march in addition to all of
that joe biden has requested another 33
billion dollars for ukraine
and that request includes funding for
quote longer-range artillery of a
heavier caliber than the howitzers we've
already been sending there in other
words we're sending artillery to ukraine
that could easily strike russian
territory and we're sending 33 billion
dollars to do it now how much is 33
billion in a moment when congress is
writing checks for trillions well to put
it into context 33 billion dollars is
more than double what the bide
administration spends protecting our
national borders and that's just one
check to ukraine but it's double the
annual budget to protect our borders the
byte administration in fact it's more
than double just requested 15 billion
for the entire budget for u.s customs
and border protection
and just 8 billion for the u.s
immigration and customs enforcement
so
we're spending twice on their borders
what we spend on our own in one request
in one week
how much is 33 billion well it's more
than we spend on veterans affairs every
month taking care of our own veterans
and the saddest point of all this is it
hasn't caused the russians to withdraw
from ukraine and no one's claiming that
it will it hasn't bankrupted putin it
hasn't crippled the russian economy it
certainly hurt our economy
what's going on here
well the daily mail is reporting that a
russian oligarch with close ties to
vladimir putin he's on the bad guy list
right no
because he met with the president's son
in moscow several times to discuss
investment deals so that oligarch
strangely is being sanctioned by the uk
but not by the biden administration by
administration for all its bellicose
talk about russia has decided not to
sanction the one oligarch
who's friends with the president's son
just to restate
this has nothing to do with ukraine the
war in ukraine does not have
anything to do with ukraine the
long-term fortunes of the country or the
health and safety of its people
has it to do with a lot of other things
the bite administration's request for
example for ukraine aid
didn't see this coming includes a
pathway to citizenship for afghan
refugees
their spouses and children quote the
secretary of homeland security in the
secretary's discretion may adjust the
status of an afghan national to that of
an individual lawfully admitted for
permanent residence oh so in an aid
package meant to defend
the borders of another sovereign nation
we continue to degrade our own bet you
didn't think defending ukrainian
democracy meant admitting tens thousands
of more foreign nationals into this
country overnight
if you want to know why our leaders are
determined to escalate this conflict
there's your answer it means more power
for them
it means revenge for the 2016 election
and if that means triggering a nuclear
conflict between our nation and theirs
so be it subscribe to the fox news
youtube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from tucker
carlson tonight